[MUSIC PLAYING]
LANGSTON BELTON: In Marvel
Studios' Black Panther--
Wakanda Forever, we get to
visit the underwater nation
of Talokan.
And to find out how those
incredible scenes were filmed,
I'm talking to Visual Effects
Supervisor Geoffrey Baumann.
Geoff, how are you?
GEOFFREY BAUMANN: I'm
very well, Langston.
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
LANGSTON BELTON:
Great to have you.
Now, I heard that for the
underwater scenes in the film,
you actually shot underwater.
Now, why did the team choose
to take on that challenge?
GEOFFREY BAUMANN: One of
the most important things
in Ryan Coogler's storytelling
is the authenticity
of where characters come from.
And I think part of
that here is combining
an underwater world
with a culture
that we can all relate to.
Early on, Ryan had made it
clear that he wanted to shoot
as much as possible underwater.
Now, there's
logistical challenges
that come along with
that process, for sure,
not just from the technical
side of equipment, tanks and all
that stuff as well, but also
the abilities of the talent
as well.
Are the performers comfortable
with going underwater?
Not only are they
comfortable, are they still
able to perform underwater?
Is Ryan able to give
direction underwater?
It was quite a challenge, both
due to the physics of being
underwater, as well
as the visual aspects
of storytelling, of color
and cameras underwater.
So it was a big challenge to
show strength, movement, speed,
and all of those
aspects underwater,
while at the same time staying
true to MCU expectations,
if you will.
LANGSTON BELTON: The underwater
performances are next level.
How did the cast prepare?
GEOFFREY BAUMANN: We often
shot, whenever possible,
an entire scene underwater
with our performers
after they've gone
through rigorous training
with our stunt department in
order to hold their breath
for a multitude of minutes,
three, four, or five,
six minute long breath
holds in a tank for them
to understand how
to move in water.
And the thought was even
if we did then transition
into a dry for wet world,
there would be a little bit
of muscle memory that
was there for how
they had to move around.
Chris Denison, our
underwater stunt coordinator,
and our marine team
and the safety team
did an amazing job of
making all of the performers
feel comfortable in water.
It was a multiple-week-long
process of them just
coming to the tank,
hanging out at the surface,
learning how to do
their breath holds.
It's methodical but it's also
somewhat meditation in a way,
where you need to
kind of really get
your mind to relax and be at
ease as you hold your breath.
LANGSTON BELTON:
So once the actors
were ready to go, how
did the production
team go about shooting
the underwater scenes?
GEOFFREY BAUMANN: We did
the previews ahead of time
to try to figure out what
the angles that Ryan wanted.
And then we would try to take
the performers through each
of their scenes with
a small set piece
that was kind of the center
of the story and shoot that.
And then that
would be assembled.
And then we would often then go
back into a dry-for-wet world
and then repeat the same
process, knowing what it looked
like in the wet-for-wet world.
The performers were
aware of how they moved.
But the dry-for-wet
world then allowed
both Ryan and Autumn, our DP,
to light it the way they wanted.
So there was then
the ability for them
to be able to interact with
the performers in a way
that you don't necessarily
have underwater.
When Namor tells the
Talokanil that they're
going to go attack Wakanda,
the dry-for-wet world
was his throne room.
And it was essentially a backing
that the art department had
built, knowing that
we probably had
to replace a bunch of the of
the set, costumes, et cetera.
LANGSTON BELTON: So with so many
visual complexities of water,
how did the team
apply visual effects
to create the underwater
look of these scenes?
GEOFFREY BAUMANN: We needed
a base, a baseline for us
to understand what
water looked like.
It's a place that some
of us are familiar with.
But in the depths
of the sea, it's
still a very unfamiliar
world for most of us.
We tried to really, again,
jump back to those early tests
and use those as our guide
for what water should be like
and what the lighting of the CG
world should be like as well.
We started playing
with how light travels
and what colors Autumn liked
and Ryan liked underwater
so that we could
try to stay true,
again, to the reality of water.
The piece that I'm
most proud of is
that we were able to include as
many characteristics of water
as possible so turbidity,
marine snow that affect clarity
so that it isn't crystal clear,
but at the same time finding
a balance so that there is
focus, so that as a viewer,
you're immersed in this world.
And you understand you're
underwater without having
to process it too much.
But yet at the same time,
there is a clear point
of focus for each shot.
And that was something that Ryan
really wanted to stay true to,
of color absorption
and the colors
that disappear underwater.
And I think because we did that
early on, it allowed us in post
to continue to sit with
the studio and the rest
of the filmmakers
to kind of show what
underwater truly looked like.
And I think that
that was something
that I believe for the most
part we were able to deliver
on pretty successfully.
LANGSTON BELTON: I'd say so.
You and the team did
an incredible job.
Geoff, thank you so much
for chatting with us.
And all of you at home,
make sure to rewatch
every moment of
underwater action
in Marvel Studios'
Black Panther--
Wakanda Forever, coming
soon exclusively to Disney+.
[MUSIC PLAYING]